hey we're rhett and link from good
mythical morning and we're here to
answer the internet
[Laughter]
okay would you rather a fight mike tyson
or b
sound like him for the rest of your life
wow dude's got an interesting
i think can you do it i can't do it
launch i'm not even gonna try
i saw uh footage of him like
shadow boxing like within like like a
week ago
and uh so even current mike tyson i
would
all right well no i'm gonna go with the
voice because it would kill me he
wouldn't know
that this would kill me if he hit me i
would then begin talking like him for
the rest of my life
right so i'm gonna say all the above
would you rather spend the rest of your
life in a country music video or a rap
music video
oh that's tough i mean i'm actually you
know we're big fans of
classic country music and
90s rap i i love hip hop i mean there's
a lot you get
i mean you can have a you can have an
exormant
lifestyle in a rap music video it's a
lot of excess all at once though
whereas in the country music video you
get to be see yourself as a child
and then you get to see yourself as a
teenager and then like as an adult
and then you get to die in the music
video right
you get to live your whole life in a
country music video yeah go to heaven
sometimes yeah yeah i think that's the
implication all country music singers
think they're going to heaven
is that true though yeah country
definitely uh no i'm going with hip-hop
we're hedging our bets if you were a
general
in the civil war and you could get a
t-rex
or modern war tank to fight on your side
what are you taking the t-rex how do you
know if a t-rex
is on your side technically well let's
say you have it like
it's like a trained t-rex
[Laughter]
the train tears okay all right okay he
will he will do your bidding
am i bare back in this t-rex yeah boy
think about this that
about the statues think about the
statues of you the
civil war general on the back of a
dinosaur just for that just for your
legacy to be that like out
no one's going to tear down that statue
regardless of whether you're for the
confederacy or not
you know nobody's going to tear down a
t-rex statue
you got to go with that
t-rex if you weren't clear would you
rather live
with your parents for the rest of your
life or always have to use toilet paper
as napkins okay this the toilet
always use toilet paper as napkins i
mean i can fold a piece of toilet paper
and make it look pretty impressive
yeah origami that stuff now i've been um
yeah there's been days when i've i've
been on the tp exclusively
um i mean it it really breaks apart but
i mean at the end of the day i'm not i'm
not sleeping in my parents basement
yeah my parents don't even have a
basement those parents aren't together
which one would get me i don't want him
to have to fight all over again who am i
going to live with
you made this very complicated uh yeah
toilet paper
would you rather spend the rest of your
life blind or inside an olive garden
y'all don't get us talking about blind
people we're only going to talk about
olive garden
you know the thing you know the thing
about
olive garden yeah that's right
uh yeah you know what hey i mean
bottomless
bottomless breadsticks salad and
sometimes pasta right
most of them have windows so it's not
like it's like solitary confinement or
anything
yeah and anybody i mean anybody you want
anybody you can convince to come to an
olive garden you could have a
relationship with
i think i'd rather be blind
[Laughter]
would you rather fight 100 duck-sized
horses
or one horse-sized duck i thought about
this quite a bit oh you
what yeah this is that what you were
doing this morning
yeah uh i definitely
i'm going for the 100 duck sized horses
because
you're not going to be interacting with
more than like six or seven at a time
because they're gonna they're
gonna form assuming they're gonna form
like a perimeter around you
and as long as you can keep your feet
moving i can take out a duck-sized horse
with
these boots you got us talking about
kicking ducks
this is supposed to help our career
right hey but they're they're attacking
you though this is self-defense man
okay but i mean i just kind of want to
see a duck the size of a horse
this is like just just a point i mean if
a feather falls off imagine getting that
in your cap
that's true yeah good point you're gonna
need a bigger cap
you have a choice between a sum of money
and world peace how much money would it
take for you to give
up world peace got a number i can only
tell you're going to be a world peace
guy but you got a number
everybody's got a number man
i mean would people know that i had this
opportunity will they know that i passed
that world peace
yes yes okay so i'll be the richest man
in the world but
the world will suck because i'm yeah
the world the world's the same well the
world kind of okay
the world doesn't suck for us but it
sucks for most people which means that
it really sucks
yeah uh i think seven billion people
like 20 of us have a good one
yeah there's no price no price i would
take
if i could bring the world peace is that
the right answer
i think so would you rather your
pet have a dog's personality and a cat
body
or cat's personality in a dog body
this is this is so easy for me because i
live this
my dog jade um is a dog
except she acts like a cat she's a lap
cat she just curls up in my lap and just
sits there she
put her put her put her head on my hand
she doesn't
she doesn't purr or meow um i'm trying
to train my dog
she would be a cat in there i love her
yeah okay that's easy for you for me the
reason that i prefer dogs over cats is
their personality it's not that
i i don't have any aesthetic issues with
cats really
i mean have you seen their butthole like
directly yeah yeah yeah i try not i try
to keep
i try to keep eye to eye contact with
most cats uh
so i i would put the dog personality
into the cat
would you rather wear high heels or a
belly shirt this is interesting because
we've done both on good mythical morning
time we had a high heel challenge
and then we also wrote a song about
discovering our belly buttons and then
like revealing them to the world
i don't know how to heel challenge uh
you just wear high heels and you do
it was actually the high heel lumberjack
challenge yeah
so we did things lumberjacks would do um
but we were wearing high heels
like single lumberjack diddy and dance
around
or um the heels are tough man
the mid they are really really tough
midriff is great
yeah yeah i mean yeah we're actually
trying to bring the male midriff back
see you guys are good though yeah
[Laughter]
if you had to get a lip tattoo what
would it say um
right there
insert here maybe for food
so people would know where to put the
food i might
probably say don't talk to me because
if you have a tattoo on your face even
if it's hidden on the back of your lip
that's kind of the message right yeah
don't talk to me
i just walk at you yeah i love it last
one
all right the last one if every time you
finish sex a song played
what song would you want it to be
usually i finished sex while the song is
still going
i love the phrase finish set
like i've never i've never heard that
term
great great job on your game guys
inventing phrases like when you finish
sex
well i'll be honest that's usually how
it goes yeah you know it's not like in
the movies it's just
over now yeah it just kind of when sex
fizzles out
i don't even remember the question what
song what song do you want to cap
off your sexual experience it's got to
be something speed related
speed really yeah like
like uh lenny kravitz it ain't over till
it's over yeah
but it but it is over because i just
finished sex is that the song
that we were listening to last night
yeah not after we had sex
yeah that's a good song it's because we
it's got this classic classic intro
baby it ain't over till it's over lenny
kravitz and it is over can i see it
still is because as long as i'm having
sex with my wife you're having sex with
your wife
exclusively okay yeah from here on out
that's the way it's going to be and
and uh we so we can both use the same
song unless we're like
doing one of those vacations where we're
sharing a room you know it's like two
double beds like things get if things
get bad for us financially and we got to
start going on vacation together and
sharing a room
at that point we probably should have
separate songs and they should be on
headphones
this bit has not been good for our
the careers civil war blind people
and then finishing sex with i don't even
know what you were
talking about or confessing thank you
you